[Music]
and not my fault news
you're gonna love this it's never my
fault i am always right
gina's gonna love this and you're gonna
love it let's hear it oh
it's submitted by yoki whenever i'm
reading i always intentionally don't
look at the next line because i want to
get excited
i always do it i love it oh i'm so
excited
yes come on girl i want to know a white
teen
is denying that she is intentionally
posing as a black woman on
instagram have you seen that [ __ ] but
i'll get to the other girl the one thing
i told her about that and she said that
you tweeted about it and i was like i
saw that the girl that photoshopped
it's so exciting one person at a time
sorry we gotta calm down this is so high
pitched everything is
i'm with you girl i'm just sitting in
between the white table over here
and the body is going we're gonna white
anxiety i'm the one going deaf over here
between these both good it's a good
article it's a good article this table
is feeling my nails
i'm like it's good this is emma
she's 19. she's from sweden how can she
pose black
all she got to do is put on a little
kinky wig okay okay okay okay
this is what she looks like on instagram
oh whoa
that's crazy that's the best look that's
good though
like that's a good blackberry oh oh no
she looks white there yeah she looks
right there but the other one was really
good
oh that's pretty good she looks like
black it's hot that [ __ ] looks nuts
it looks nuts she looks good though
that's true
but the other one is her outfits are
five yeah
oh my god fashion nova right there
sponsors
fashion nova who won't [ __ ] respond
my email i'm calling you out right now
well they got cardi b now why are they
wanting to know
nobody wants me whatever i don't get the
hips for it anyways
i need an ass yeah so emma she has a
pretty popular instagram account
and so recently someone like outed her i
saw that tweet oh my god i'm like set
and then like it was
a photo the first photo that i showed
you guys and then like comparison saying
like she's
full white like full on white she
doesn't look full white they use the
specific
they use the specifications my black
face makeup routine
i know you can't say but she was funny
your face it was like everything though
yeah she did like body paint do you
think is that a spray tan at all or do
you think that's
i don't know like it looks like she's
just a naturally morena like
that's the thing that's the thing that i
was from sweden and so like there were
no no maybe nationality-wise but her
ethnicity what gio is saying is she
doesn't look like me
i look [ __ ] white she doesn't look
like white white white so she even
admitted herself she's
white like full on white yeah but
hispanics are white too right
but not really right so this is white
well yes
hispanic news is saying spaniards are
really white they look white
but from spain not like the same kind of
white though you know where's 23 and me
let's see that right what's your kind of
white yelling for her
so for emma someone someone sent her a
message
oh i'll read the first one and beau's
reason oh okay
okay the person saying sending it to her
they said emma is it true you're white
and just posing as a colored person
because
how much you want to admit that the
person writing that message is white
being offended for the
other people of color yeah sure no one
knows this college
so then they continue because someone
posted your before photos and i have so
questions i have okay um
she says yes i'm white and i've never
claimed to be anything else and by the
way
there are no before pictures the
pictures that have been spread are just
two different pictures taken on two
different seasons of the year
before summer and one after summer and
of course there's a difference in my
skin tone
because i get 10 shades tanned naturally
when i've been in the sun i'm not posing
as a colored
person as you claim
i've never been or tried to be or look
black i was born with naturally curly
hair and my skin gets very easily tan in
the sun
there's a picture of several of last
year and the year before where you can
see that my tan looks exactly the same
after each summer
but that was not a tan but no that was
that was airbrushed that was a black
girl bodybuilding yeah
she put that [ __ ] all over her i gotta
say do y'all remember rachel dolezal yes
yeah look all rachel did was put on she
put on a little bit of orange makeup and
she just put on like a kinky wig
this this girl that's a real black face
you can't yeah she like you gotta you
gotta give her props for she did good
yeah this is her makeup
okay girl shadestar it's like way darker
but hold on
it matches her neck it matches her neck
she's trying to match her back because i
tan my body but not my face either
so it's a really strong yeah she is cute
unless you start off with her neck for
just kidding i don't know so here's the
thing so i've been i've been going back
and forth about it i've been going back
and forth about it because
there are people like if i like for me i
can go like super light-skinned like
south korean or i can go straight up
like dark tan
cambodia like really yeah yeah like if i
really wanted to right so here's the
thing so
what i want to know is where the line is
because yeah she got she might have
gotten
stupid tan i've seen you see white girls
in hawaii they can get like tan tan
you know and then i'm just trying to
figure out like which part makes her
makes people think she's trying to be
black yeah girls also get their lips
done it's the weave i think like
well it's her actual hair but she she
puts her hair
in braids who cares for texture but it's
also like
i guess a lot of people are bothered by
the way she
portrays okay okay the color here is a
little that is
real that's kind of [ __ ] nuts and her
hair is like black in that
wait what were the other photos but
there's pictures like her hair is dark
dark dark
look as a person that is black 365 days
out of the year
i like i think she looks good she does
i think i think i would not that i would
be offended but i think i would see why
people are offended if she was just like
oh my black people i'm so glad
she just looks like a kardashian this
just that's what a lot of people are
saying because that's nip uh what's her
face what's her name
uh the main one kim yes yeah more than i
remember kim kardashian
i'm sorry kim's pissed she sees that
she's [ __ ] i'm sorry kim if you're
watching
but yeah she wore that exact same dress
and i just hate it because like let's
just assume that this girl is just
trying to be
[ __ ] bomb as [ __ ] on ig right and
just doing it for the gram
and now there's all these other people
just like their own [ __ ] insecurities
and that whole outrage culture again
just being like this [ __ ]
just because they're hating that she's
[ __ ] cute so it's like one
combination is not right like you can
get your lips done in your hair but not
the skin you can get your skin done but
then
they're saying here i've heard arguments
that even cornrows are like having
braids
i had two braids in my hair once and
people went nuts but that it was dumb as
[ __ ] so that necklace right there that's
hella mexican okay
music video from 2003. i'm just confused
you know what
honestly okay if we lightened her up she
would just look like a white girl in
this picture right
what i kind of don't know though she has
like kind of
ethnic feelings she does even in the
other even in the other picture she
looks like she could be biracial
but she's got she's [ __ ] beautiful
though she's right she's gorgeous
think of it this way they said she lives
in sweden what if one she didn't even
think of the cultural sensitivity that
people are gonna have
and then two what if she actually is
like wow you know people that look like
this are so beautiful and we don't see
this in sweden
[ __ ] it if i can make myself look like
this i want to be it dude
have you guys seen the cholo culture in
[ __ ] japan
yeah oh yeah they dress like straight up
cholos but see this is what i get
confused about because like
where's the line between inspire
inspired by and appropriation because
now it seems like anything you're
inspired by if you're inspired by a
culture
you can't anything is appropriation okay
so
that's that's that's going to lead me to
the next girl at work
now this [ __ ] i think this one's a
little because this girl
she looks stupid and also it's straight
up photoshop yeah
but but it looks i'm mad that it looks
so good all right so this
girl she's a makeup artist this is what
she looks like there's about oh i did
see this one
like this is like nightmare before
christmas loving
like and this is what she looks like now
wow ooh she's cute she photoshopped out
i like creases she photoshopped to give
herself an
uh monolith so this is before whoa
after this white car looks more asian
than my asian ass
do you think asian people find that
offensive no that's her
that's her well now it looks like she's
just trying to look like different
people to show off like her [ __ ]
like candy johnson can do that with
things she can make herself look like a
cartoon but she's like 24
7. like all yeah i saw like um
she deleted her instagram because i went
to lurk it and then like
her last like 20 posts she just
completely was like no
this is what i look like yeah and then
she even did a video too like to prove
she has monolids but they were like from
down here
that's a little much like come on wait
why would it why would an asian people
just be like damn
thank you because they were like you're
fetishizing it
that's the whole the whole argument but
it's like it's like if some
people are offended then they speak for
all the people yeah
they're the loudest too yeah it's like
you might not be offended by the girl
that looks like she's trying to be black
but then like these these group of black
people are offended so now they're
speaking for everybody yeah well
i think the main difference is like
while we've all been sitting here like
i'll be like oh i give this a pass or i
get none of us have sat here and said
you're not allowed to do this which is
what other people do they
they like said it like it's the law and
we're just saying like oh i like this or
i don't i think people make things about
them too much
like they're like well i'm as a latina
you are not allowed to
wear hoop earrings yeah as a latina i'm
offended and it's like
okay chill a girl like no one's making
play why are you making it i go out of
my way to try to act as white and look
as white as i can because i don't want
to hurt nobody's feelings i won't wear
hoop earrings you can't wear braids
yeah exactly i like appropriating first
american peoples or you could be
appropriating black people
and you can't it's like i don't know
where the line is anymore what's up
because
it used to be like remember like six
years ago like those feather earrings
were really in
i don't think you could wear those
anymore anything with feathers you're
appropriating
[Music]
huh